oh my god lord take me away
[Music]
over the years 90 day fiance has
captured some of the worst breakdowns
you're gonna find love's
physical
fights and cringe-worthy moments
reality tv has ever seen he has told
people that i smell and i peed on him
and 2021 was no different
hey 90 day fans fam it's melisia these
are the moments that make you ask
yourself
where in the world do they find these
people they're also the moments that
keep us coming back i know that's right
let's count down the top seven most
memorable breakups breakdowns and cringe
raving moments on 90 day fiance this
year
you know what you know what
this is over coming in at number seven
stephanie's explosive fight with ryan
after he slept with her without a condom
while she was visiting him in belize hey
brian
are you afraid of the truth ryan
you're good you're good what you're
you're good that you slept with me last
night with no condom after i said i
don't trust your ass you got it out
crinkle crinkle crinkle i thought we
were good no one was good in that
situation crinkle crinkle
she's talking about are you afraid of
the truth stephanie was the one who
didn't want to accept that she was
clearly being used for money i've spent
thousands on his gifts by this man that
was 25 years younger than her
20 20
eat my ass
that line
still leaves me speechless don't you
lie to me ryan after ryan left she
called him and he brought up her
sleeping with his cousin harris
stephanie was out here getting it in do
you want to talk about life
so why would you lie about her oh my god
are you kidding me ha ha
[Music]
take me away
you know what you know what
this is over right then and there
stephanie broke up with him and you know
who she called next
harris
she had no shame in her game can you
come here and see me i mean i know it's
asking a lot but i need to see your face
in a matter of days she did a good old
switcheroo and started dating ryan's
cousin and the sad part about it is
harris had no shame in admitting that he
was using stephanie to get to america
it's only one time in a history you get
a good break like that and to be honest
a part of me thinks deep down
she might have been okay with that oh
stephanie was something else during her
time on the show i wonder where she is
now anybody know
no okay oh shut up you're a nasty
son
the number six spot goes to angela
cursing out michael so bad that you
would have thought he was her worst
enemy on the street
not you know her husband you're an ugly
son of a [ __ ] son of a [ __ ]
after her weight loss and breast
reduction surgeries i can tell you he
was a butt he was a total ass angela had
suspicions that michael was cheating on
her so she went to see if she could get
a tracker put on his phone and things
went left
in a matter of seconds you mind cutting
on the location on your
the i.t guy didn't know what to
like that you do what you know you're a
woman so well you don't know me worth it
oh shut up you're a nasty
son of a [ __ ]
i don't see them
[ __ ] i do that openly you're the one
that's the nice guy i never claim to be
tonight's [ __ ] i am that [ __ ] your
mama warned you about remember that
later on when angela got home she was
still pissed and she ended up putting
michael's business out there to all of
us listen i should have left you when i
went up there and your penis wasn't what
you said it was you lied from the
beginning michael his little thing
well hey she's still with him so it
obviously can't be that bad and i oh
yeah
let's move on i'm sorry i have to tell
you the council of a vegan
number five natalie hysterically crying
after mike called off their wedding the
day of the ceremony just three days
before her visa expired i don't know
what to say
i'm leaving america tomorrow i'm
honestly freaked out and scared i have
to do it because i wouldn't really go
here i give you one last hug natalie no
i could not michael i could not why you
do this to me you think it's good for me
to do what wrong you'll do this to me
although his approach was tacky the
funny thing about it is mike was
actually making the best decision by
calling off the wedding considering that
they did eventually get married and are
now no longer together
that's proof you always gotta trust your
gut if he would have stuck to his guns
it would have saved him a lot of time
stress and oh yeah
[Music]
who pay for you live right now how you
live you're not working now legal you
not have money how you live right now
without mike mike support you for you
pay for apartment for clothes for food
you pay for yourself that's for you
i know the answer
me too
yes she has she has my bank card okay
still to this day during the tell-all
michael revealed that after they broke
up
she was still using his card
nine girls were sending me inappropriate
messages and images of like you know
they're boobs speaking of hail naw the
number four spot goes to stephen
admitting to talking to nine women
online after marrying galena
and i was saying like wow i have a
really long tongue it's too bad i don't
know how to use it and confessing to the
world that he wants to have a threesome
so i feel like i have a lot of sexual
energy so like there's a lot of
repression going on within myself
it would be easier if we were able to
find a way where i wouldn't have to
repress
these urges and these feelings as much
what urges are you talking about
i really want to have a threesome
despite the fact that stephen has been
trying to tell everyone else how to live
right in god's eyes by pushing his
religion on others i can't believe
stephen right now he's trying to convert
my mom
i think it's not appropriate this moment
made the list because it clearly depicts
one of the hardest parts of being a
viewer which is watching someone who's
seemingly innocent like alina continues
to sacrifice herself for what i think is
a lesson subpar relationship well thank
you for
taking care of me everyone
but i just already decided that i'm
gonna give another chance and that's
gonna be the last time thank you baby
if you gotta go through all of that
why not just be by yourself yes we all
have had our moments i know i have but
when you can clearly see someone is
settling for less and they can be
treated better
it's frustrating
[Music]
all right y'all knew i had to throw this
one in here the number three spot goes
to asuelu tackling his sister and
dragging his mom out of the house things
got tense after asuelu gave kalani a
baby blanket for christmas
knowing that she doesn't want any more
kids right now i want to have a big
family so hopefully my wife will make my
dreams come true
and i don't want to keep being pressured
into having a baby
things took a turn for the worst after
his mom and sister i don't have a
relationship with them try to back up
swallow up and convince kalani clonie
look at me i'm selfless
i got nine children and i'm fine that's
when her ride-or-die sister coliny said
oh no
not today
[Music]
that was a lot the standout moment for
me was when kalani's dad low came in
super
it was late typical bad behavior
you mind your own business
tell my husband what to do
these brand new beats what was all these
how do you like that now it's no shock
that angela made it twice on this list
she comes in hot in that hot red
jumpsuit at number two the moment when
she flashed her boobs to the world
during the happily ever after tell-all
she did it twice
can you accept the fact that she cannot
have a child
angela made her usual jump from 20 to
100. well they'll see as they watch the
show you know i do things for a reason
after michael's aunt lydia started
discussing the need for michael to have
a baby and no problem with that what we
talked about surrogate's mother which
she agreed late lydia you started your
business i've heard you keep putting
yourself in
my mind
it didn't take long for angela to make
her way to the camera and show those
things off maripovich style you mind
your own business too
tell my husband what to do
these brand new puppies what's all these
now how do you like that now
[Applause]
you too michael
you won't see them got them again
you
she said she does things for a reason
but
why she flashed everyone
it's still unclear all right time to
reveal the worst moment on 90 day fiance
this year and before you hop in the
comments and say no that wasn't it
remember
this is just my opinion
the number one spot goes to andre and
libby's brother charlie's explosive
brawl
[Music]
this was such a moment because the
tension behind this fight was building
for so long
during the previous season they had
their little pull and tug before the
mondovan wedding because charlie was
asking andre's family about his past
so i hate to say it but
it was about time they needed to get it
out it's been a while now the fight
started after libby's dad invited all of
his kids over because they were upset
that he allowed andre into the family
business he's actually taking money out
of our pocket for our family chuck
thought he could create some sort of
kumbaya moment between everyone but then
charlie who hadn't seen his family in
months due to the drama walked through
the door call the cops think i said
don't tell me what to do
come
oh
it got so bad chuck was even about to
fake a heart attack
you want me to have a heart attack right
now
i'm about to have a heart attack
although libby's family has been accused
of staging some of their drama a part of
me almost wishes that it was scripted so
i wouldn't have to go through all of
this
crap that i'm going through
i gave this moment the top spot because
it was unfortunate to see libby's family
fall apart that night her sister rebecca
left the house saying this my family
won't ever be the same after tonight no
no way and her husband was completely
over it they're both blamed
guys too and all it's all toxic
i don't want anything to do with this
family anymore
charlie felt disowned by his dad which
is tough
whose shot are you on
and chuck
chuck cried like a baby a really uh
traumatic night seeing my family
so
so polarized
i don't write down what the best thing
is
all i know is that i want my family to
heal
i want my family to come back
that's what i want
i don't want to see this i don't want to
see my family
i felt for him in that moment family
stress
is another level of stress especially if
you're tight-knit if i'm not being a
good dad
[Music]
but hopefully things have gotten better
for them and if not hopefully one day
they will
alright 90 day fans fam that does it for
90 day fiance's wildest moments of 2021
happy holidays and happy new year
i wish you health love happiness and
success in 2022
and i'm sending that same energy to all
the 90 day cast members hey
remember we're all a work in progress
all right i'll see you next time
[Music]